and an actor's voice an audible
chameleon from that lone voice thousand
characters can emerge Camaros for
example I'm a robot named ping and I
just want to learn how to swim wow
thanks where's Paul Rudd I don't know
ah
don't hurt me bear I'm just in inner
city mouse with a lisp really I don't
know I don't know so you begin a lot of
animation work no no I changed my an
email so I'm figuring it's you know it's
all gonna come yeah piling in when
relations when they figure it out and
stuff yeah you you probably no no no no
my phone's been acting all weird those
probably like at our change or maybe it
could be at our change you never know I
mean with all this technology phones
here the nominees for the best animated
short film Adam in dog minkumu fresh
guacamole s head over heels timothy
records and folic Ronan O'Reilly Maggie
Simpson in the longest day care David
Silva paper man John Kahrs and the Oscar
goes to paper man John cause this is the
first Academy Award nomination
or John Prine
thanks to the Academy especially this
year they got the shorts out to all the
nominees to everyone at Disney
particularly John Lasseter Ed Catmull
and Andrew Milstein who have just been
great at revitalizing the studio -
Christina read my producer the cast and
crew everyone who helped on it they made
it so much better than I could ever have
hoped - my wife the amazing Jenny Rim
and to my kids Ben and Johnny I'll see
you tonight bye